hello good evening everybody we are
excited to kick you off thank you for
waiting with us
we are going to get started in just a
little bit so everyone sit tight and
we're going to have a wonderful fun
night normally if this were in person
we would say who is hiring unfortunately
there's only three people on screen
right now so you can't just stand up in
your seat and say hey i'm hiring so if
you would like to hire somebody
go to the ny hacker slack and go to the
job postings channel and post your job
likewise if you want to get hired go to
the job postings channel and find a job
hopefully soon we'll be back and we can
actually find jobs in person but anyways
go to the job posting it's a really
great way to get hired or to hire
someone
since i am on camera i am hiring as
always we always have a lot of positions
available we are growing looking for
linux admins we are looking for sales
looking for shiny devs looking for data
scientists so if you want a job with me
and my company lander analytics go to
landeranalytics.com
careers we have a whole bunch of roles
up there uh we're fun to work with
uh in our news hope everyone saw that r
4.2 came out recently
i'm very excited because the native bass
pipe now works with an underscore
placeholder in case you want to pipe the
argument to a different spot so i am
very very excited about that
in
our normal tradition which i know we
can't all be together
i got my pizza today from rocco's
you can see it was cooked in a pan you
can tell by the gaps and the browning
good cheese lock because you know these
grandma slices ought to have cheese lock
um this isn't sicilian it's a grandma
slice
those of you in the new york long island
area are probably familiar with grandma
slices those of you outside maybe not
familiar it's like a sicilian but the
dough doesn't rise first it's so that
they cook it before the dough can rise
it's a nice dense crust
so those of you who are eating or
drinking or whatever
hop in the chat let us know where you
got your pizza from or your dumplings or
your pretzels or your flat bread of
pepperoni and pineapple
that's a flat bread it's not pizza so
we'll let that one go jeff h
if anyone else has good pizza or good
food or anywhere let's share where
you're eating from because you know
those of you who used to come to the
in-person meet up know how important
pizza was to our events uh and so i'm
keeping the i'm keeping the flame alive
we go to places like rocco's every month
different places so everyone else is too
uh we got um pav bhaji that's like an
indian sloppy joe and from chicago cool
yeah let us know where you are folks too
let us know your food and let us know
where you're coming in from that's
always fun to see people
jeff h as close as you can get
we got squash soup
all right cool so hopefully everyone's
enjoying your food let us know in the
chat i love seeing this
um
you have pizza from somewhere did you
get pizza
no i didn't i haven't eaten much yet oh
we need to get you some food with that
orlando he's not having pizza much like
josiah well we'll talk later josiah
we'll fix that
um we have a new website i know i talked
about it last month but if you folks go
to my hackard.org it has been
dramatically redesigned thanks to joe
marlow and nicole del judas they have
done an amazing job designing our new
meetup website in our using our markdown
i highly recommend checking it out you
can see our pizza poll which is actually
using the process of that's being
completely revamped you can see all the
pat we've had 12 13 year 13 years
actually this month is the 13th
anniversary oh my goodness this is the
13th anniversary of the meetup it's been
going on for 13 years i'm really excited
about this yeah
um so you want to see slide shows from
the past 13 years and videos in the past
eight years roughly go to nyhackgar.org
and check out all this beautiful website
that joe marlow and nicole del judas put
together we are very very excited about
that um it was it's a very good website
much better than the previous one which
i had built the previous one and it just
wasn't as amazing as it is now it was
bad let's be honest it was bad now it's
amazing so we're very happy about that
we want to thank ecohealth alliance for
setting us up with the zoom link they've
been doing that for over two years now
actually now it's exactly two years it
started oh god april 2020 is when we had
our first virtual meetup so not only is
this the 13th anniversary of the meetup
it's the second anniversary of us being
virtual
so take that for what it is
but we have excited we are pretty
excited we have a few things happening
next month may
will be another virtual meetup all right
it'll be 100 virtual meetup in may uh we
don't we have the speaker ready to be
announced soon we'll announce in the
next few days um so may will be virtual
but then june
we just 95
was always in a confidence interval
secure venue space in midtown manhattan
for our first in-person and virtual
meetup in two years
it's going to be a hybrid folks we're
going to be in person those of you in
new york city will be there in person
those of you not in new york city we are
going to have it live streamed on
youtube
all right
we are very very excited about this we
are not quite ready to announce the
details yet it will be the first week in
june in fact it will be june 1st or 2nd
uh we are very excited about this not
gonna have venue details yet i don't
want to jinx anything
once we get everything locked down i am
so very excited to have this in person
and virtual so if anyone wants to come
in from i see people from saudi arabia
from vermont from london from south
london from brazil miami
south england sorry not south london
from all from austin from all over the
place buenos aires orlando so folks
chicago i saw you'll also be able to
join us
in june when we're a person in virtual
we're going to try to make it like equal
event right the virtual and for in
person will be just as good
that said we have this space but we
can't rely on one spot to have space
every month so if you have an office
space that can hold about a hundred
people in your cafeteria in your break
room at your desk wherever anywhere near
in manhattan uh especially all of new
york city i don't mind you know having
events all over the city but you know to
make it most uh um accessible to people
coming from the tri-state area manhattan
is kind of important so if you have
space anywhere in manhattan let us know
we need to have a whole bunch of hosts
in the past we had four regular spaces
we would go between do you have office
space let us know because we're excited
for june but we want to make sure july
august september is available to us
we have another in-person event coming
in june it is our eighth annual it's
eight years now new york r conference
we are really really excited about the
new york art conference it's been
virtual the past two years this year it
will be both in person and virtual
they'll be in person in midtown east at
the french institute
and it'll be virtual on hopkin the
platform that's really great that we've
used the past two years there will be
workshops on june 8th and that would be
max kuhn teaching machine learning dean
natali teaching chinese euroneansons
teaching python for our users and
malcolm barrett and lucy d'agostino
mcgowan talking about causal inference
um malcolm the causal inference workshop
will be only virtual
max kuhn and your own yancels will be
both in person and virtual and dnatalia
will just be
in person
then the actual conference itself takes
place june 9th through 10th we have an
amazing line of the speakers we have
andrew gellman asamatumi we have max
[ __ ] we have west mckinney sarah
contenzaro and then we have a special
live recording of a podcast john crone
who um actually did recording last year
last year we'll be doing another
recording and his guest this time will
be hilary mason so we're very excited
for this live podcast of john cronin and
hillary mason it's going to be a really
fun time
and of course if your company is looking
to sponsor either for
um
hiring or to sell your services let us
know
again it'll be both in person and
virtual
and lastly if you remember this meetup
you get a discount use code ny hack r
for a 20 discount go to rstats.ai and
use the code ny hack r for 20 discount
since you're here tonight you could use
code my hack r30 for a 30 discount to
the conference so i hope you can come
all right with all that questions go to
slack we're going to give away free
ticket at the new york r conference
we're going to be in person soon you can
check out on your website lots of cool
stuff
so
i am very excited to announce this next
speaker
i first met him at a conference i was
giving a workshop and he was uh one of
the attendees and immediately you know
like we talked to each other had a fun
time chatting i see them at a bunch of
my workshops i think i've seen each
other in person other places
and i am
very excited not just selfishly because
i am i enjoy spatial analytics because i
think everyone's really going to enjoy
this talk everyone please give a virtual
welcome applause to josiah as you bring
him on to the virtual states thank you
josiah welcome
thanks jared hey everyone my name is
josiah perry i'm super excited to be
with y'all tonight to discuss
exploratory spatial data analysis in r
um
i do feel obliged to tell you a little
bit about myself and i promise to keep
it rather short i'm not really fond of
watching recorded videos and fast
forward 10 minutes and then it's still a
biography so um
i work at a market research firm called
the npd group which is headquartered in
new york um but i'm actually in virginia
right now
my background is in the social sciences
in 2020 right as a pandemic started i
graduated from northeastern university
with a master's degree in urban
informatics
prior to that i studied sociology and
anthropology at a small state school in
new hampshire and then
during that time i realized i was
actually really interested in statistics
in geographic information systems so i
left
with a
some minors there but i wouldn't call
myself a math expert i got a d in calc
2. i pretty much struggled with
tricks up but it was around 2016 when i
really started to take r seriously
so
my goal for today is to introduce the
fundamentals of spatial data
the first law of geography
the objective of exploratory spatial
data analysis or esda
and then the fundamentals of the
introduction to the sf-dep r package
which i just found on crayon a couple
like a week or so ago
um
so before we start talking about
exploratory spatial data analysis i
think it's really important that we
review exploratory data analysis
um
and i really like this quote from the
national institute of standards and
technology or nist they define eda as
follows exploratory data analysis is an
approach philosophy for data analysis
that employs a variety of techniques
mostly graphical to maximize insight
into a data set uncover underlying
structure extract important variables
detect outliers and anomalies
another really great quote
from r for data science by having
becomes says eda is not a formal process
with a strict set of rules more than
anything eda is a state of mind
so in essence the objective of eda is to
discover potentially explicable patterns
it's an art and not a science uh in to
me it's all about getting a tactile feel
of our data
maybe develop an intuition for where
things may or may not belong what
patterns you
that may exist in the data that you may
not have discovered or what could be
discovered further
and as said in the nist quote
eda
heavily relies on data visualization to
interrogate data and it also makes use
of descriptive statistics for
identifying outliers or any sort of
other thing there
pictures are worth a thousand words
graphs and charts probably 10 000.
so i do want to talk about exploratory
spatial data analysis but before we do
that i think it's really important that
we talk about spatial data
and
there are
so many types of spatial data and you're
familiar with some even if you don't
think you know spatial data analysis
it comes from tons and tons of different
sources of domains such as
transportation
ecology environmental sciences
demography and probably a ton more
so just to explore a few
here we have a
some charts on the right of street
networks in four cities new york paris
tunis and atlanta um street networks are
probably one of the most
common and familiar types of spatial
data that we might be exposed to
from these spatial
networks here this road networks we can
learn a lot about maybe how old urban
areas are like for the platoonists
what type of transportation is
emphasized where parks may be
and this type of data can be used for
transportation planning and routing so
think of things like google maps
on this graphic here we can see the
distribution of flowers in pune india
and
how the color of those flowers change
by month um this this is actually a
really cool gift that was created by my
friend and former classmate at
northeastern assembled
and ecologists have been using spatial
data to track locations of plant species
throughout landscapes evaluate how
habitat for
these species
looks
you can think about this from the
biological perspective where species are
so on and so forth
another one which i find super cool uh
is satellite imagery so uh these are big
cameras
in space which takes pictures of the
earth
so this one we have here on the right is
imagery derived from the landsat 8
satellite
satellite imagery is the backbone of the
remote sensing domain
and satellites can capture all sorts of
color ranges that we
can't see with our own eyes so we can
use those light combinations to show
different things in landscape for
example we can explore where water is or
urban surfaces
or
vegetation so on and so forth and
satellite imagery is
becoming even more widespread and
available and it's used everywhere from
weather forecasting to military
intelligence right
and this
actually in specific this this third um
section of this uh
this uh satellite imagery is what really
got me interested uh in spatial analysis
where we can use satellite imagery to
look at
urban landscapes
so that's really what got me excited
about spatial data
and then here we have
regional data so on this
corepleft map which is a
map that has
associates colors to predetermined
regions
it was created by the census bureau to
show places that they deemed hard to
survey populations and choropleth maps
are probably the most common type of
geospatial visualization that there is
you've probably made one um or
seen it in the new york times or
washington post or wherever you might
have seen one
and
the corporates use regional data so the
regional data is uh these enclosed
shapes that we see here and regions can
be any predefined shape in space
so it could be tracks counties zoning
areas states you name it but uh the
challenge with this type of data is that
these boundaries can be rather arbitrary
and can introduce uh if there's any
economist here aggregation bias
or in the geographic terminology it's a
modifiable aerial unit problem where
the value associated with the shape is
determined based on how we draw it right
so that's one of the downsides of this
types of data but it's what we're going
to be exploring a lot today
and then also
it couldn't leave out digital elevation
models so here we can see a dem for
short that was created with ray shader
by tyler morgan wall it is so cool what
you can do in our
with spatial data i just couldn't omit
it
and dems are really really awesome
because they can be used for natural
disaster planning identify
flood plains landslide
landslide areas where one should put a
runway for an airport
so on and so forth
and
while i do find the term big data to be
a little overused i would be remiss if i
didn't mention the impacts that the
growth of big data has really had on
spatial data
much and much of the data that is touted
as big is naturally spatial spatial
so some pertinent examples might be the
use of light detection and ranging or
lidar
point of sale data
point of interest data
internet of things devices and sensors
municipal services like 3-1-1 that was
really really big for me and my program
at northeastern
in road network data so things like
openstreetmap
lidar
is a type of remote sensing imagery
it works by shooting lasers out and
measuring the amount of time it takes
for that laser to hit a surface and come
back so by measuring that amount of time
we can figure out the distance it takes
or distance between that
camera in essence
and then from that we can create entire
3d environments so lidar is used in
autonomous vehicles to continually
evaluate like surrounding areas
and identify objects and that kind of
things so with the development of drones
we're able to get a lot more
lidar data and geospatial data
now pos data i think is really cool
there might be a lot of folks in the
retail business here
for example at
npd we track sales from over 600 000
retailers each sale is recorded
each sale happens at a store somewhere
and those stores are located in a
physical location right so thus that
those sales data is actually spatial
data
and
while these are used to typically
attract performance and create other
metrics i think there's a lot of
potential here to
identify spatial attributes as well
and
poi data or point of interest data is
another really
fast-growing industry of data vendors so
point of interest is kind of a vague
term but in essence it's any anything
that might be of interest right so it
might be a monument hiking trail a
public restroom a museum
so for example
yelp is a really great resource for um
restaurant point of interests
companies like zillow and trulia
for tracking apartments and houses that
are for sale those are really good
points of interested out
airbnb is used widely in econometrics
research
and there's also just a number of
growing vendors such as safecraft and
carto that sell this kind of data that's
really helpful to supplement other kinds
of data that you might already have
while this data is interesting and
helpful
it's a little violating because they
collect this data by um
tracking your location through apps that
you might have right so just turn off
location services when you can
so all this spatial data
typically falls into one of two
categories
vector data or raster data so vector
data is coordinate based so i like to
remember this is point lines and
polygons it's fun to say um these are
all based on coordinates
whereas rasters like the satellite
imagery we saw is a grid of cells
or a pixel where each cell has a value
so when you have like a jpeg you have a
value for red green and blue the same
thing here is true for raster data
now i'm going to be focusing exclusively
on vector data here on out and there are
three types of vector data that we're
going to encounter points so this is a
coordinate point specified by the
longitude and the latitude and sometimes
there's an elevation but that's less
common
and
lines are
created by connecting two or more points
so that creates a line segment
and then polygons are four or more
points that create close shape so
there's three vertices but you need to
have a point land on where it started to
enclose the shape
so that's what a polygon is
here we can see these visual
representations so on the left hand side
we have some points
uh
this next uh section here is we have
lines created from those points
and then we have polygons created from
those points as well
but then we look to the raster section
to the right we can see that the raster
is more or less an approximation of
those points
so depending on what you're looking at
or the type of data that you might have
polygons might be a better
representation of a region or shape
so as i said we're gonna be looking
strictly at vector data moving forward
and then within exploratory spatial data
analysis there are two types of uh
analysis that we might encounter and
there are some names for these which
follow which are point pattern and
lattice
point pattern is just kind of what it
sounds like it's the analysis of point
data so that would be like species
uh locations um airbnb locations things
like that
uh the second one is the lattice
perspective
and that's what we're gonna be focusing
on from here on out if you're interested
in point pattern protect me afterwards i
find some good resources
but a lattice is a grid and
polygons um
in the lattice perspective we think of
lattice as grid data or polygon data so
many of the techniques in exploratory
spatial data analysis fall into this
lattice category
here are some nice lattices we have a
nice glass of pie
a lattice for your garden and then some
sort of network class
so one more thing before we dive into
exploratory spatial data analysis
the first law of geography so in 1970
waldo tobler wrote this quote which is
now the most important quote in
geography
he said everything is related to
everything else
but near things are more related than
distant things
and that's really the premise that we're
going to be after an exploratory spatial
data analysis esda
things that are close to each other tend
to be more related and things that are
further apart
but everything's flooded
so esda extends eda spatial
relationships we're focusing on how
values are distributed across a
landscape
we're wanting to explore um tilde's
first law right are
like values clustered together
um are things further apart
are there values in the landscape that
are dramatically different than what
it's expected right so an esda typically
focuses on two
topics those are two spatial
characteristics spatial autocorrelation
and spatial heterogeneity
special spatial autocorrelation is the
correlation between a value
in the values surrounding it or its
neighbors or its neighborhood
or a spatial heterogeneity
is the uneven distribution of values
across the landscape
much of esda is really focused on this
idea of spatial autocorrelation and that
helps inform um analyses that might
identify what are called spatial regimes
um
what not so
es eda in general compares part to the
whole so how does one observation look
in context to everything else or in
context to its subset of the data
whereas
esda compares apart to its neighboring
parts not necessarily the entirety
so we like to evaluate a location's
value relative to the values of its
neighborhood
and the neighborhood is fundamental to
esdf but like how do we define what a
neighborhood is
what are they
well there's
many different ways that we can
accomplish or define what a neighborhood
is but when we're thinking about lattice
data
there's
really one main way so let's to get an
idea let's just look at a chess board
this is an accurate chess board it's a
hobby of mine
uh so think of each square in this chess
board as a region or a polygon in our
data set
each one of these squares
has a neighborhood
but we need to think about how do we
actually define that neighborhood
so when we have lattice data we
typically define neighbors based on
their contiguity
and contiguity just means to be touching
or next to something
so contiguous neighbors are those
regions that touch our region of
interest or our focal region
and there are two main types of
contiguity that we refer to here
uh they're both named after the chess
pieces so rook and queen contiguity
which are based on the way that the
respective pieces move in the chess
board
rooks can move vertically and
horizontally
uh and then queens can move the same
ways of rooks so vertically horizontally
and then along both diagonals that it
has
so
um queen so there's rook continuity and
there's queen contiguity and rook
contiguity is defined by what's touching
on its sides
and then queen contiguity is what
touches our region of interest on its
sides and also its vertices
so let's look at the contiguity of the
queen's gambit great netflix show also
my favorite chess opening
so this white dot is default position d4
or the coordinates 4 4.
if we take d4 as our focal point the
squares that it touches on its sides are
c4
d3
d5 and e4 squares
so based on rook contiguity we have four
neighbors
just based on their sides
okay
now
if we take a look at queen contiguity
every surrounding region is considered a
neighbor and this is generally the
preferred type of contiguity
when we when we choose rook contiguity
it's typically for a theoretical reason
that makes sense for your data so in my
background of urban sciences we're
actually generally
interested in queen contiguity because
we want to know about neighborhood
effects how does um one region impact
the surround immediately surrounding
ones
so
in this case we have four additional
neighbors the ones that are touching by
the vertices
so that's c3 c5 e3 and e5
so now we have
eight total neighbors in our
neighborhood
so if we created a connectivity map of
all the squares in a chess board for
rook and queen contiguity
this is how it would look like
so
um left-hand side we can see only
vertical horizontal lines
on the right side we have the same lines
but now we have diagonals going across
and that's kind of how we can envision
contiquity
but
spatial data is never really as nice as
a grid unless you um maybe make a grid
and count the number of points in those
grids right that's a different story
so here we can see the queen contiguity
of a region in france and its neighbors
the region of interest is black and its
neighbors are gray
so we can see that all surrounding
points are
sorry all surrounding regions are
considered a neighbor
so that helps us frame how we define a
neighborhood
but naturally the next question is well
how do we evaluate what this
neighborhood is so we really do this by
comparing a point value so a region of
interest to the surrounding neighborhood
point values
to compare the neighborhood
to compare the observed value to the
neighborhood we create what's called a
spatial lag
the spatial lag is just the expected
value or the average value for that
neighborhood
but when we compare to our neighborhood
how much influence should each neighbor
have in calculating that expected value
right that's a tough question
um when we think of toddlers first law
where
nearer things are more similar to
distant distal things it would only be
natural for the neighbors that are
closer to have more influence
the influence that a region has in
identifying the expected value is
measured as the spatial weight
but when we think about polygons it's
just shapes right
there's no effective way of measuring
distance because what are you measuring
distance from one vertex one point on
the side and there's an infinite number
of distances you can calculate from
inside of the polygon right
so it's kind of a challenge we're kind
of doing a conundrum here so um with
this lattice perspective we're using um
between contiguity we often choose what
are called row standardized facial
weights where
each neighbor if it's touching is given
an equal weight
it's defined by this formula here um but
i
think of it in r terms and it's way
easier to just think of this as one
divided by the number of neighbors that
we have
so if we have four neighbors it would be
each neighbor would have a value of 0.25
that's how much importance it has in
calculating that spatial lag or that
expected value
so
the spatial lag what is the average
value of the neighborhood
with the spatial weights that we have we
can now calculate what this expected
value for a neighborhood is
might get a tiny bit mathy here but it's
just basically arithmetic um you should
be able to either understand it
immediately or if you're like me maybe
after an hour or two just staring at it
and trying to figure out yourself
um
so if we
some of you might be familiar with time
series analysis where a lag compares a
point in time with the same
the same
thing at a later point in time or after
some specific specified amount of time
so for example you might compare today's
values to yesterday's values and that
could help you get an idea of something
the idea is kind of similar in spatial
analysis right so rather than comparing
the value um
to itself we're comparing it to its
neighboring values
and as stated the spatial lag is just
the average uh the weighted average
of the neighbor the values contained in
our neighborhood right
so
we multiply the spatial weights
by an observed variable y for each of
its neighbors
then we add all those things up to get
the lag and then we just do this for
every single
observation in their respective
neighbors
so for example say we have a random
variable x the value of x at region i is
hundred
it has
uh
four neighbors
the neighbors have values of
5 40 135
this is represented by xj j is typically
used to identify neighbors
we can then calculate the spatial
weights by dividing one by the number of
neighbors we have
so that would be 0.25 and then we
multiply
those neighbor values by their spatial
weights and then we add them up
so here for those values we get a
spatial lag or expected value weighted
average of 45.
so now let's think let's go back to the
chessboard so every square here on the
left-hand side is the uh index of
or sorry the
row value the row index here so we have
one through 64. one on the bottom left
and 64 on the top right the left hand
side is just the board itself and then
on the right hand side we have the
spatial lag for each uh square here
so
um
on the bottom left square a1 it has the
value one and its neighbors are two
ten and nine so if we go to the same
position on the
chart to the right if a spatial lag of
seven
and we can see on the right it might not
be so clear here but there's there's
some smoothing that happens with the
values so whenever we take a an average
there's typically some smoothing that
occurs
and
let's actually apply this to a real map
right so on the left hand side uh we
have the observed crime rate in 1830s
france comes from a very famous data set
called gary
and on the right hand side we have the
spatial lag for that
we can see that it's kind of been
smoothed out
across the entire region
and then we can actually use this lag to
get a sense of how an observed region
compares to its neighbors
using some other visual visualization
techniques
let's create a scatter plot of the
observed variable in the lagged variable
this scatter plot of the observed
variable and the spatial lag
is referred to as a moran plot it's
based on the moran's eye statistic which
we'll go over in a little bit
this plot can be super helpful to show
us
the spatial autocorrelation of these
variables as well as
some natural clustering that they might
fall into so on the x-axis we have the
original variable on the y we have the
lagged variable and the slope
uh of the regression line between these
two variables actually spatial
autocorrelation but we'll worry about
worry about that a bit more later
so here we have a very very basic moran
plot um in addition to the scatter plot
we like to we
place
intercepts on the x and y axes of the
average of each respective variable so
in essence we're
kind of plotting the z-scores here
and these quadrants actually help us
identify
clusters in our data set
so these quadrants show how our values
cluster in space
so the top right it indicates where high
observed values are surrounded by other
high values
now going down to the second quadrant or
the bottom right we have high values
which are clustered around
low
values in this neighborhood and in the
bottom left we have
low values which are surrounded also by
other low values
and then on the top left we have low
values which are surrounded by high
values and the top left and bottom right
quadrants are actually very interesting
right because they can help us identify
places that um we might see some a lot
of spatial inequality right so if we're
looking at um
household income we might show
uh a place neck where there's a lot of
observed inequality around some maybe
very real boundaries whether it's like a
city line
uh a freeway or something like that
now if we plot a smooth line on here
with the
linear regression that's the spatial
autocorrelation
and so what is spatial autocorrelation
it it's the tendency of like values to
cluster in space
and it's always based on this assumption
of spatial randomness where the the null
hypothesis is that everything is just
randomly distributed across space
when data is systematically located on
the landscape that is exhibiting spatial
autocorrelation so when values
uh like values cluster together we'll
call that positive spatial
autocorrelation
and when dissimilar values cluster
together that's called negative spatial
autocorrelation
um and the most common measure of
spatial autocorrelation is called the
moran's eye or in this case i'm gonna
call it the global or enzyme
so just like the pearson's r correlation
coefficient it ranges from zero to one
or nice
negative one to one where negative one
is
perfect negative spatial autocorrelation
where dissimilar values are
placed together
zero is complete spatial randomness it's
completely arbitrary where these values
might fall on the map
and then one is perfect spatial
autocorrelation where there's large very
strong clustering of
like values together
um this is a cross product between the
spatial lag and the observed variable
that's mathematics beyond me i'm sure
jared could probably explain it it's
just
not for me um
so
if we look at this plot again we can see
that the moran's i value the spatial
autocorrelation here is
0.411 so that's a moderate amount of
spatial autocorrelation but is it
significant
and that brings us to the topic of
inference
and
inference for spatial analysis is a
little bit different we again as i said
we always start with the null hypothesis
of spatial randomness but traditional
hypothesis testing like the t-test uses
an assumption of normality which isn't
always actually met in spatial data
so
we then we actually use a permutation
based inference instead
so what we do is we create random
permutations of our data set and create
a reference distribution where we
compare our observed statistic so we'll
calc we'll randomly shuffle our data
calculate moran's eye say 99 times and
then compare that to the observed value
so
the value for calculating the simulated
p-value is r plus one
divided by m plus one so it's really
just a ratio we're sorry where r is the
number of times that a random uh
miran's eye
is more extreme than the observed one so
it's really how many times is a random
moran's eye more extreme
than what we expect
so um as i said this uses conditional
permutation and this is a once i got
conditional permutation
spatial esva kind of made a lot more
sense to me and how we kind of
understand
what is a significant cluster so
conditional permutation is basically
randomly shuffling the neighbors for
every observation
so
say you have an observation i and it has
four neighbors we randomly shuffle those
four neighbors
um for every single observation but i
can never be its own neighbor because
that would just makes wouldn't make
sense um so we do this a bunch of times
we calculate the marian's eye for these
randomized neighbors
and then we kind of find this ratio to
calculate that simulated p-value
and it's really important to note that
simulated p-values are dependent upon
how many simulations you run right so
i'm always cautious of p-values but when
we're doing simulated when we're using
simulated p values be even more cautious
um
luke anslin from university chicago
who's kind of like the godfather of a
lot of this stuff uh recommends using a
cutoff of like .01 or .001 as a
significant cutoff but just always be
careful and cognizant of that
so here we have three different
histograms of our reference
distributions one with 99 simulations
one with 999 simulations
and
9999 simulations
on the right hand side we can see uh
there's a vertical line and that
represents the observed moran's eye
and the histogram
is the
simulated moran's eye whenever we
shuffle that data set so this helps us
get an intuition of like is this
actually an extreme uh moran's eye do we
expect this under spatial randomness and
given our distributions here we can see
that
the
i guess
mean value is zero so fully spatial
written it's completely spatially random
okay
so that's a good background uh into esda
and now i want to introduce sfdep which
is a tiny inter a tidier interface to
the sp for package for spatial
dependence
the motivation for this actually
happened back in 2019 where i was taking
a class with jeff boeing on advanced
spatial analytics i was
the class was taught in python using a
library called pysal
as an r programmer i was kind of miffed
i was like i don't want to use python
but after a while i was actually i
learned a lot it was actually a really
great library and then my mind was
completely blown by spatial regression
and um in the back of my mind i was like
i want to do this in r there's not a b
tool for it so on and so forth
um
and then two years later just bid
pandemic i don't know what caused this
but i really wanted to relearn spatial
statistic and during that time i i
discovered the spdep package which is
used for
this exploratory spatial data analysis
but in my experience it felt a little
idiosyncratic for a tiny first person
right that's that's me
and particularly
um a lot of this functionality is almost
tidy verse compliant or
i wouldn't say compliant but um
interoperable
uh so one challenge was like i wanted to
create a neighbors list but it lacked
the explicit list class so i couldn't uh
use that in mutate right so i created an
issue
i was shot down because it's based on
compliant but it was still very
insightful and very motivational
so immediately after i created an r
package called sfweight to just kind of
create my own interface to help me do
this thing um
i didn't like it
it had a heavy reliance on dplyr
non-standard evaluation and i ignored a
lot of the
advice that was provided in that issue
so as a next step i decided let me just
learn more about spdap so i
created a pull request introduced some
new functions into the process i learned
a whole lot and decided on a new
interface for this um
and i'm becoming a huge fan of spdap so
in building this new interface
i have some principles that i was trying
to inject here so the first is that i'm
always going to use sf objects when
possible right or actually in general
always use sf for geometry
and i'm always going to turn return d
plier friendly objects when possible so
that's going to be a vector
a list
or a data frame of the same length or
same number of rows as our
data frame that we're using right now
so and then also i wanted to make sure
that the functionality is not dependent
on dplyr right and that kind of comes
down to the next
bullet point where we have minimal and
very light dependencies so
um the heaviest dependency i have in
this case is going to be spdep and then
some nice things like the cli for having
nice fun error and
warning messages
and also
every every so i have some new functions
in here that aren't available in spdap
but the important thing is that it
should all be compliant right so
everything is implemented using spdep
um objects like nb
and list w class lists
so
to the fun stuff so how do we make
neighbors um to do this there's a
function called st contiguities and this
takes a geometry column by default it
uses queen
contiguities
and
returns a list of class and b
and here's an example of using this just
directly on an sfc object or the
geometry of an sf object and this is how
that nv class
list prints out if you've used sp depth
this should look familiar
but the nice thing is this is actually
pipe friendly so i can put this inside
of a mutate function call or in this
case transmute just to return what i
have
here
so i can pass in the geometry column and
then the resultant object
is this nv list column where each
element is an integer vector
and those elements contain the row
positions of our neighbors so here the
first observation has um
neighbors in row positions 36 37 67 and
69.
then from our uh neighbors lists we can
actually create spatial weights
and this takes an nb or class object so
a neighbor's list
and
we use the function st weights and it
provides row standardized weights by
default there are other uh
spatial weights functions for points or
kernel density and things like that
but each weight in this case is the same
and then each element of the resulted
list is a numeric vector which contains
the weight for each indexed observation
in and b
so here we have an example of
finding the neighbors and then
calculating the spatial length
and here we can see the spatial rates
okay so spatial lag
to calculate the spatial lag we use the
st lag function we provide a numeric
vector and the neighbors and the lists
um
we have some nice use cases the moran
plot we can identify neighborhood
averages it's useful in regression
so this is what it would look like right
if we wanted to create that lag variable
for the previously defined variable
here we can see the
observed value and the lagged value
okay
so we can then use these
uh in conjunction with dplyr to classify
our moran plot here we have a mutate
call which uses case when to kind of
partition these data along those those
axes um if you want to explore this more
later they'll we'll have the slides for
you um but we can see that we're
defining these clusters here's high high
high low low low
okay
so the basics of creating a miran plot
we take that now classified um data
frame we pass it into ggplot where we're
putting on the x-axis the observed
variable y-axis the lagged variable
we're going to color based that cluster
variable that we just created we're
going to add the points
the intercepts and then a theme for good
luck
there we go
so again we can use this this plot to
classify our neighbors but can we dig in
a bit more
yes
so this is where local indicators of
spatial association come in or leases
leases evaluate a
statistic at the neighborhood level
so um things like moran's eye we can
evaluate at the neighborhood level the
observed value
and um we use what's called the local
moran uh it's also the original lisa
and the least the the local moran
evaluates the auto correlation within
each cluster it uses the same
conditional permutation but now the
statistic is at every single observation
okay
and to do this we use the local moran
function this calculates moran's i for
each point it identifies clusters for us
and it calculates three different p
values that we could choose from
and it returns a tight a data frame that
we can then
use tidyr to kind of clean up a little
bit
so here this is the approach we have our
our
sf object it has our neighbors and our
weights
then we create a new column called lisa
this is going to be a data frame column
and uh we're passing in the variable of
interest the neighbors and the weights
and then we actually unnest it
to kind of remove that data frame column
those the data from columns were always
a challenge for me
uh the second uh section just
illustrates how to select those columns
of interest and here we can see the
results
so this is the output of the local moran
there's a ton of stuff to work with
it contains a local moran the expected
value the variance the skew the kurtosis
and then three different p-values so
p-i-i is the p-value if we assumed um
normality
i
p-i-sim
is uh using the permutation uh
permutation approach we discussed but
it's also using a ranked base
calculation the last one here p folded
sim is the approach that's take taken in
py uh
which is the python library
which i is my preference here so this uh
kind of follows along with that
equation that we just kind of walked
through a little bit
and then here we have three different
classifications for these clusters so
how we determine our clusters really
depends on where we split our values
some people don't like to use the mean
because it's very easily um
i guess affected by outliers so people
might use the median
and here we can just choose which we
prefer mean
median or
what is
created in pi cell so this is a
replication of the pysol clusters as
well
um
so uh
maybe not always
so often we don't want to show the
places that might be deemed
insignificant so we could use this
resultant data frame create a new column
called cluster
which um
if it doesn't meet some threshold we
provide that as an n a value and then we
can plot our our graphic right so this
this map here helps us identify um
clusters in france along this uh
variable which is the crime rate right
so in this bottom right we can see where
low values are clustered together
here we can see that this value has a
low value of crime but it's surrounded
by other areas that have a higher crime
rate
here the same thing here this where it's
red indicates that these are high
places with high crime rates that are
surrounded by others that also have high
crime rates and these are significantly
more crime rates
okay it's cool
um
so now i wanted to go through
a quick work example in uh our studio
with educational attainment rates in
boston
i'm gonna stop my share and if there's
any questions i can answer while i get
our studio but i'd be happy to do so
we could save them for the end so
go ahead and okay
cool okay
so
um very briefly i just wanted to show
what the typical workflow for me kind of
feels like it looks like
so this uh repository this is data is
all in script here is going to be
available on github
i'll have the link for you
so what we do is we'll load sf sfdep and
the tidy verse we'll read some data that
we have in a geojson file for boston
it's now read as an sf object it's very
nice so the first thing that we'll do in
the eda process is evaluate
the distribution so in this case i'm
interested in
educational attainment rates throughout
boston
so based on this it doesn't seem to be
anything
um too wild except for the fact there
might be some locations that have no
uh recorded educational attainment for a
bachelor's degree based in the census
so
while this looks fine how does this look
across the landscape or how does this
look across the census tracts in boston
so i'm going to create a coropleth map
using ggplot and
[Music]
fill this based on this bachelor's
attainment rate based on the census so
here we can see we have some darker
areas and if you've been to boston this
is the roxbury area in matapan and then
this is also east boston up here which
is kind of funny because it's kind of
north um and then here we have uh
downtown back bays south end kind of
stuff so richer more affluent areas
so
this kind of leads the question
is there some spatial autocorrelation in
here right um
it looks like there might be we can see
a lot of dark areas around by dark areas
a lot more brighter areas so
um to do that we'll first start by
creating our neighbor's interstitial
weights and stores an object called boss
and
b um
and then uh there's a couple ways we can
do this i've done this in a summarized
call to calculate the global moran
um
we'll pull this out
it's doing our permutations for 499
samples here and we can see that we have
a
auto correlation statistic of
0.596 so 0.6
that's quite a lot um
and we can see it's rather significant
so to me that means there might be
something more to explore here
so the next thing for me to explore is
always going to be the
moran plot see if there's anything that
looks kind of out of the ordinary here
and we see we have some points
in these two quadrants that indicate
maybe some interesting outliers where
places might have um
lower values right by higher values
so um to explore that a little bit more
we calculated moran
using
local moraine instead of a mutate we're
unnesting it and then we're just filling
it with meat with the average uh
cluster here but this
is informative but it's not the most
informative right like we were really
interested in places that kind of are um
that that seem to be it's that have more
spatial autocorrelation than what we'd
assume under spatial randomness so we're
gonna kind of fill filter out those from
the coloring
and we're gonna do this using uh mutate
just kind of a standard fl statement and
then we can create this plot
okay so this is what we can see here so
we have a lot of um
low educational attainment uh kind of in
the roxbury area mattapan and then
higher and alston where all the college
kids live
but let's just kind of see can we uh
associate this with the neighborhoods in
boston to get a bit better idea so what
i'm doing next is i'm reading in this
neighborhood geojson
here which just has the shapes of these
neighborhoods and their names
and then i want to overlay that to this
existing plot
so if i just print this out
it's kind of clunky i can't really read
anything so um for this case i just
wanted to make an interactive
visualization plotly
just to kind of
dive around this a bit more so
um if you haven't used plotly by the way
you can just kind of wrap any ggplot and
this function ggplotly and make it
interactive
so um let's zoom in
here and get a better sense right so
here we can see that backbay is a very
which is a very affluent area has higher
educational attainment rates than east
boston right
um and we can see that south boston
which is largely becoming gentrified is
higher
um
educational attainment rates
and
our studio is located right around here
um here we can see dorchester roxbury
mattapan
so
um
yeah with that i just kind of wanted to
provide you with the introduction to um
how we kind of do this in in
our studio
and then
one last thing to share which is kind of
like
what else is there other than uh
the local moran let's find the share
screen here
so it can't just be the one statistic
right
no there's tons of things to explore
right whether it's point patterns
um defining different neighborhoods
right we can define these based on the
nearest neighbors um think places that
fall within a different
distance band or neighbors of neighbors
we can also try using different weights
we can try adding a decay using a kernel
we can try using inverse distance
we can also try exploring spatial
networks or using network
analysis tools on spatial data because
these connective these neighbors can be
turned into a network really easily so
some other measures that there are let
me move this up a little bit uh some
joint counts for evaluating binary
variables neighbor match tests to
evaluate um distances and attribute
space compared to physical space and
then also things like co-location so
we can see if there's asymmetries
between relationships our
um
7-eleven's more
uh loc located next to schools then
schools are located next to 7-elevens
and things like that
so with that i'm going to leave it and i
just want to say thank you everyone
and if there's questions i would be
happy to answer
thank you very much
if we could get a uh round of uh emoji
applause um i'll do a golf clap everyone
wants to send his emojis or some kind of
love in the in the chat uh he has an
excellent talk so thank you very much
for giving us that talk
see there's some emojis you made someone
cry even how good it was i think that's
what that emoji means i'm not quite sure
what the single teardrop means but i
think it was good so uh thank you very
much for this talk
all right first question josiah have you
played a gm parquet at all
no i haven't but uh on my to-do list is
figuring how to use geospark and that
necessitates parquet right
so
um i haven't but it's on my to-do list
yeah i i've learned a little bit i'm
afraid it's just like they're just
taking the well-known text and
converting it to well-known binary and
serializing this text i think
but i haven't played it enough
yeah i'm not the guy unfortunately yet
one day one day same here same here and
i've been playing a lot oh do you part
next question this is from me now um do
you use post gis or what do you use like
a database for this stuff
uh i don't actually so i haven't had
opportunities post uis so a lot of the
stuff that i've been focusing on is like
just urban data and while they call 311
big data it still
um ran very well by my uh m1 chip so um
i haven't had a chance to see that so if
i had post gis database i would like to
play around a lot with that
uh how uh when you say big how big are
we talking for 311
a few million
so
yeah
yeah so a lot of uh work there's
interesting work done by my former
advisor at northeastern about
custodianship uh which evaluates
three-on-one calls um and 911 calls so
it's very interesting work
very cool i'd like to see
that um we have a few more questions
that just came in and since they're in
zoom i can't copy and paste we'll do
those first then we'll get to other
questions
uh it's i don't know why i can't copy
and paste on the chat it seems like a
real issue
all right there's a question about could
you add a function to get the clusters
yeah i could i i the
predecessor um
uh sf wade had it
um
i just figured a lot of these the
functions from spdap already provides
the clusters so it's not necessary in
most cases but
it does make sense if we're only
calculating the lag and observed
variable we're not relying on
calculating all these statistics um and
i actually i think i made an issue for
myself a couple days ago to do that
so maybe soon
yeah
this is a comment more than a question
but use qs to serialize the sf object
now someone understand qs it's sort of
just like a similar to an rds object but
better and faster
i have not heard of it
well josiah looks it up from what i
understand i think it's like rds is it's
not like parquet where like i could load
it in duckdb or i could load it in
python or r or whatever but i do think
it is like a better version of rds which
will save it faster
yeah it seems like that it's inspired by
the fst package for fast saving i guess
it's made by by facebook it says really
yeah
or uses something by facebook i'll have
to read the vignette
too
all right because i know i've had issues
when using targets trying to save
massive sf objects with rds is slow but
if we could do it faster with qs that'd
be great
um there's a question about how do you
deal with multiple comparisons when
evaluating lisa is it bon peroni or
something else
yeah that's something i've seen a lot in
literature is like it's kind of an um an
outstanding problem
uh that's why people have the more
conservative
um
p-value estimates and they're using the
conditional simulation to conditional
permutations
i i haven't seen anything in the
literature that
says anything to just say be more
conservative so far and that's why we
use the conditional permutation
okay
um for chloroplasts but i'm going to
extend this beyond choroplex i'm going
to hijack this question a little bit
okay you have a preference between gg
map and tmap and i'm going to extend
that to gmsf leaflet rdec and map deck
like where are you okay
i
haven't played with so okay my whole
thing is
i know ggplot i understand the grammar
graphics pretty well
i have no reason to leave
uh ggplot there's a gm sf i can get
99 of the things that i want with that
um
so i use it i i've used leaflet but
i don't like web development so if i
ever have to touch javascript i'm kind
of out and a lot of people do a lot of
cool things in leaflet you have to touch
javascript um but if i've not been in a
place where i need to make a lot of
interactive maps so i haven't done it i
have wanted to check out map deck um it
goes into some discourse on twitter
about that recently
it looks actually really great but i
haven't done it tmap looks interesting
if it gives me like um esri vibes where
it's kind of like
old school kind of flat colors um but
again like i feel so comfortable with
ggplot i have no reason to leave ggplot
i can control everything i want
there's not a north arrow but i mean
i'm always going to be
[Laughter]
orienting my stuff northwards anyways so
i don't have a need for that
i will say i use leaflet a lot and never
touch javascript so you can do it
without touching javascript okay cool
yeah yeah i'm not saying you should go
that's not an endorsement for leaflet
necessarily but i'm saying like you know
you don't have to worry about javascript
for the one time i ever used it was i
want to build some animations which was
click quickly not worth it so have fun
using javascript
okay
i just remember like 20 2017 trying to
like add pop-ups or something
i'm good oh pop-ups are all built in now
it's so easy
[Laughter]
very easy nowadays there's i see a plus
one and a plus two for using it without
js
yeah because there's a whole ecosystem
around like leaflet there's leaf m
there's leaf gl there's leaf everything
yeah i saw like this new package for
like having offline tiling and stuff too
which seemed really cool
say it again i think i saw a new package
for having offline tiling oh i think
miles mcbain just uh blogged about that
it's like not necessarily offline but
it's like
in your firewall it's like your own
hosted
gotcha
yeah and there's all sorts of work but
also like um i'm gonna i'm gonna ask
this question have you used flat geo
buff at all
i've never heard of it i was in the
conversation a lot of the sf folks but
hey how do i store this stuff better in
a leaflet map so i can put it into this
and they're like they thought hey maybe
you could use flat geo buff and use that
as a way of streaming in data into
leaflet as needed
interesting
interesting
i've never is this like a
c library or something i think flat geo
buff it's like an i'm not sure it's c
but it's definitely some external
library then r can make use of it i
think newer versions of
sf uh of rg doll can read from flat geo
buff properly oh michael sumner um i
think you're the one that people have
talked to on twitter about this yeah
it's not geo buffs in new format
that's great that's great for being here
david says plus one for flat geo bus
apparently okay but i need to learn this
because i don't know it enough
okay
flat geo buff is a new is a new format
okay
well now i feel like a luddite at this
point
i haven't figured out how to like use
that in conjunction with leaflet so um
so uh michael sumner if you want to give
a talk
in july whenever you're physically in
new york because we're going to be back
to in person i think
you're giving a talk about how to use
flightcheck of leaflet how's that sound
michael
still say a good flight and assume
that's a yes because he said otherwise
do they still have a two-week quarantine
rule in new zealand
they probably do but we could you don't
be in america for some reason i'm sure
yeah
yeah this is the way this works folks by
the way if i see you in the chat and i
recognize you and you do something cool
um you get pulled into giving talks
um so all right so michael's i'm gonna
just message you michaels i have a lot
to talk about i'll i'll copy josiah
because there'll be a lot of cool stuff
um i knew a lot of stuff recently so
this is very pro for me
that's awesome um
so you talked about spatial lag right
yeah
what if you have both time and spatial
how do you do like a spatio-temporal
look
that's something i'm actually currently
exploring right now so esri um if you
familiar with esri they have a tool
called arcgis and it's kind of like
it is the tool that everyone uses
um for spatial data analysis and they
have something called um
they call a spacetime cube so
uh they they basically
create like a time series of
observations
um
but then keep track of the neighbors
right so they incorporate the time lag
and spatial lag to calculate
the same statistics
but
i don't understand like the nuances of
it
but uh that's that's actually my next
task of functionality to build is
um
figuring out how to actually calculate
those those time dependent um
things but also
what um
people do so there's um bivariate
measures so there's a bivariate local
moran what other folks will do are
recommended by lou ganslin the fellow
who made it who made that who created
that uh
measure
is have the same variable but time
lagged
and then spatially lacked right so so um
if you have like variable x you're
so if it's a bivariate measure it's x
and then the time lag of x right and
then you do stuff with the um neighbors
of those and calculate cross products
and things like that but um that's how
you can incorporate time on some things
presently so there's things like the
local c
which is another measure of auto
correlation which ha um there's
functionality here in sfdap and spdep
which can take any number of inputs
numeric inputs so you could include the
time lag and the spatial lag
there which might be a good way of
defining the co-location
okay where are you
auto correlation i see jeff h
space time cube
yeah there you go
jeff h is that jeff horner or is that
jeff someone else with an h because i
just see the h i think it's jeff
hollister from the epa
yeah that's cool
yeah
um um good time
i was just gonna say at that so this one
oh scott my boss at npd mentioned uh
something about um neighbors networks so
yeah you could use time series enabled
network analysis like dynamic baze nets
which is something he's teaching me
about presently right now um so yeah
there's this functionality to convert um
these neighbor lists into um
tidy graphs through a thing called sf
networks so there's like a little
interface and those can be turned into i
graphs so if there's anything that you
can do with igraph you can do it with
the spatial network anyways so um
there's a lot of places i want to go
next uh which is time series and also
network and i haven't figured out which
one i want to choose so if you if you
have a recommendation let me know oh i
like both i guess network's thing i've
been dealing with mostly with lately so
i'm going to say the network part okay
cool
yeah
personally selfish
um
before we continue on with questions i
saw someone know michael sumner said
he's want to give a talk michael message
me on twitter or linkedin or facebook or
email me or slack or whatever there's
many many ways you can touch me go to
jaillander.com contact find me there
find me on twitter message me because i
don't have your email
dm me whatever and we'll get this talk
going
um there is next question
about
um
let's see
there's a question that says do you have
a resource for getting a better hold of
spatial statistical basics like spatial
autocorrelation heterogeneity
yeah so i learned a ton so um i put the
link to the documentation here so luke
anslin this uh
gentleman at the university of chicago
um
he's like probably the most widely cited
person in this domain
he has an open source software called
geoda
which is like a ui and the toyota
documentation
is phenomenal it's not really
documentation for geoda it's just
documentation for these metrics and
these um
measures
super super great resource i linked it
there it's just
geodesigner.github.io and click the
documentation tab
and then geodatacenter has a youtube
um where
luke hanslin posts all of his online
lectures for his classes
so if i'm cooking i'll have those on in
the background uh i've learned a ton
from those and then honestly once i felt
comfortable like
with a lot of these measures i just
started reading the papers right so
it took me quite a while to like start
piecing apart these equations but i
think there's a lot to be gained from
reading the papers after you start
feeling comfortable and the nice thing
about these these papers they're like no
longer than nine pages um so it's
nothing too crazy but i i've
found
luke hanson's stuff so informative and
helpful
a well-written academic paper
it does wonders
yeah they're great to have
um continuing on to this general theme
and also the questions just coming in
and i'll go back to the ones i collated
earlier um what other fun spatial
regression tools is the art ecosystem
missing like what would you want to add
in
that's a great question i actually think
there's
a rather robust ecosystem for spatial
regression so the spatial reg package is
actually really nice
i think its documentation could use
cleaning
uh and clarification so i actually think
the the tools for facial regression that
exist today are actually pretty great
pretty great and i think there's also
another one
for origin destination um
uh
regressions that i forget the name of it
look it's called od honestly um or s
something i
s i actually is the new r package i've
seen
um
uh
which looks really cool
but from my experience or what i can
tell i think there's actually a lot of
really great tools for facial regression
i think it's um there's other things
that are needed more help
along those lines what do you use you
did mention really but the package
mentions that we use for spatial
regression or their other packages as
well
visual rag is what i'm using also if i'm
honestly if i like
if i do spatial regression it's
typically something pretty simple where
i can actually create the variables
myself so um there's something called
the spatial durbin model if i
don't quote me on this but it includes
every x and the lagged the spatial lag
of that x predictor so i can just create
the lagged predictor and include it in a
regular linear linear model so
do you need to lag y also
no but there are some models where you
could lag why
um
it depends on the specification there's
actually quite a lot and um i haven't
fully committed to memory
what
each one
is inferring
no it's real it is um
i spat that is focused mostly on ecology
and i haven't seen anything like the
things that um
that i've read from like toyota center
um and other
papers mentioned on spat stat
website but it's also
another frustration of mine that
open source technology documentation
should be open source and um the
documentation is a book which isn't
necessarily open source
uh
then
let's see what's next all right do you
have to convert your sf objects to sp
objects because you're using sp depth
no
no great question
um
no
the as svdep works it's very flexible
right because it does work with sp
objects it works with sf objects now too
um
and a lot of
great changes have been made to s uh
spdap to like use s2 for example on most
calculations by default so um
it's actually a it's a super cool
package um now that i know the guts of
it
that was going to be another question do
you have to worry about projections are
you just using s2
uh just using s2 um they'll they'll be
warnings so it's
like so since uh
spdap is using s2 if it doesn't match it
or if it's like using that long or
whatever triggers those warnings it
provides those warnings so that's why i
like to rely on
sv them so i don't have to build those
out um
sbdep is really really great it's just
the interface that's a little bit
different right um
yeah speaking of s2 something i keep
dealing with lately keep getting like um
invalid polygons and i can't do st make
validators like nothing i do makes them
valid i'm like i don't know what i'm
doing yeah
there's also something really
interesting i i want to understand where
they actually have like interesting
measures for distance for polygons
where they
like compare distances for i think like
every vertex of a neighboring polygon
or of all polygons and um creates a
different measure of distance where the
typical measure of distance is just like
the centroid um which is so bad so um
just because like where is the center of
a shape um so i think sv does a lot of
cool stuff there as well
there is a note from michael sumner
saying projections but he just gave us
an ellipses so we'll need more
information michael about why you don't
like us too or if that's what you are
saying but look it's got to be a talk
soon
that's just yeah that's that's decided
um that's idiots i know there are sorts
of different measures like closest point
of polygons or average distances all
sorts of things yeah
do you have a method for spatial data
analogous to resampling in which you try
different definitions in the
neighborhood boundaries
i
i guess you need a really good
theoretical reason to define different
neighbors right um i don't think that
kind of
resampling approach would be
effective here unless you have a reason
to define your neighborhoods totally
different
maybe you want to try the same measure
using um contiguous neighbors or
distance band based neighbors or have
different weights that use that
introduce like a decay
um
but i don't think just arbitrarily
creating your
neighbors is informative or helpful
anyway right because then we're kind of
losing track of what um
is that spatial relationship
fair
i guess you sort of did resample when
like during your permutations of your
permuting which ones are actually
neighbors or not
yeah because we're trying to simulate
complete randomness right um by
just arbitrarily choosing um for a
uniform distribution right
so in that case yes absolutely
and if you want to try that out there's
a function called
cond perm and b
uh to conditionally permute that
neighbors list
and you did talk about i think miranda
eyes how you did it like
how to differently weight points based
on their distance from
you can do that yeah so um
that
if would follow the point pattern uh
approach
so um
typically if you're going to be doing
points the
most common way of identifying neighbors
is just through decay nearest neighbors
decay nearest neighbors based on
distance and then
you can use their distances as weights
but also what you can do is
use a kernel so
those kernels their intention is to
introduce more decay
um so say you have
five five-point neighbors but they're
all at different distances so what you
can do is create this use a kernel uh
that rather than just kind of like using
their pure distances it introduces some
sort of additional decay um or it
inverts the distances um to
kind of
add more influence to nearer points than
more distant ones
this is a comment but glmm fields is a
niche package for bayesian regression
with multivariate t random fields
yeah i'm just opening up the package so
i have it to look at later nice
um and
is uh there's not someone responding to
we're going to talk about modeling
packages that's another way
then um is sf depth on cran
yes
congratulations i know that was a thing
you're working on
there's a lot of undocumented things
that you got to get right
so even though i was passing all my
local checks it took some extra time to
get there but i wanted to get it on
there before this happened so
it is okay so you can i probably missed
that step you could install it from
crayon using installer packages
so i've been following you on twitter of
your uh your journey to have of having
to get this up there and it was
it seemed hard as it always is so
congratulations on getting it up there
yeah yeah i i didn't know you had to
have uh our packages in single quotes in
the description of your description
for example
yeah and there's arbitrary rules that
aren't necessarily told to you but you
know once you submit they tell you
you're wrong then you can make it right
yeah i mean i just feel like it's nice
but it's a lot of extra steps where
if it was just in the check i could get
it there a little bit
faster fewer interruptions yeah yep
um this is uh a selfish question
um
but
you know
i know i have a lot of you know i've a
lot of friends and a wife who does a lot
of brain imaging and the brain is a 3d
map
um have you applied any of your stuff
you didn't mention altitude have you
like done 3d spatial stuff with um sf
depth
no but i know michael sumner here is
always talking about considering meshes
um
no i haven't i i think part of that is
just that my interest um is largely
around like urban things so like
like i mentioned airbnb diamond one
crime educational attainment and all
those are very flat
um
i think that is a very
valid thing to explore um
i just don't know how it would fit into
these statistics that i'm familiar with
right like how does elevation play i
guess you could have
the distance from elevation play an
important factor right um because you're
talking distance along his uh altitude
that does play but
that's a very minor
change
yeah i'm interested i know i remember my
ta in grad school did spatial stuff he
had to think about you know they
actually did he actually did like a
group lasso using uh parts of the brain
had to build a network about what we're
connecting what wasn't so over here i
think that was everything oh and michael
sumner coming in talking about how you
can apply spatial to non-geo stuff yep
so that is a uh and again the brain is
just a map right it is it's not just a
map it's just one way to look at it lots
of things oh there's one more question
it's there's always a sneaking
this is a question i've been using this
a lot uh i want to hear uh josiah's take
on the uber's h3 for bidding your data i
was just thinking about this the other
day so um i think it's so cool
uh
i there's a package on github that i've
been waiting for over a year to be on
crayon but i don't think anyone's taking
the steps
um
it's it's really really really nice i
just don't have the familiarity with c
and make files to do it myself you're
talking about the h3 package that's
still sitting there on github it's like
crazy
is a username yeah yeah yeah
i wanted to use that one uh but since it
wasn't on crayon there's another one
called h3 jsr
yeah that used the v8 as a way to yeah
and so i used that and
i've been using the not for fitting but
for like finding things that are just
near each other so i'm doing a lot of
distance between points so i'm using the
hexagons to find what are near each
other and then once i find what they're
near each other i can find what's sort
of near those and i can compute much
smaller distance matrices so i like it
um so jeff h i really like using it and
it's
fast like you asked for it and it comes
back like that with with the h3
indicators but yeah yeah absolutely and
it's also really cool because um
there's so the company safegraph which i
mentioned earlier they sell tons of
point of interest data
and
they
i think they're like incubating a
company called place key
and place key
is like
it creates this um
unique identifier for every poi at least
in the us i know they're expanding to
canada and all of those are based on
the h3 grid that it falls in
so um if you can have
like they have an api where you can just
send
uh addresses that like they handle the
formatting and so on and so forth and it
returns um
this place keys that you you can kind of
geolink it geolocate and join across um
data sets and not have to like
perfect addresses and all the
idiosyncrasies across databases um i
think it's really cool and it's based on
h3 as well um and that's how i actually
learned about h3 was through that so the
applications are wide and it's super
super cool
yeah
it's been helpful for me so because i
was gonna get into it um i do i do love
h3 just even for like i use h3 to go
from a point to a hex to hex to a
different point um and it's been very
very helpful
that's awesome yeah
all right so with that just a few
reminders to close things out and
there's another question while i'm
giving a reminder so be it um
remember we have maze virtual june will
be both in person and virtual we have
the new york r conference coming up june
8th through 10th use code ny hack r30
for 30 discount on both the workshops
and the conference itself
um
check out nyhackr.org you get tickets
for the comments that are stats.ai uh
check out myhackr.org for the meetup
site including in this video and these
slides will be posted to that site in a
few days so i guess if you're watching
this not right now you're watching this
recorder you're already at the site but
it is available you have 10 10 years 13
years worth of slideshows today is the
13th anniversary of the meetup uh just a
big thank you to josiah for this
wonderful talk everyone let's give
another let's give another golf clap to
him
and then uh thank you everyone for being
here thank you josiah for talking and
i'll see everyone next month stay tuned
for the next announcement bye everybody
awesome thanks jared thank you